[Music]
oh
stop
am i cursed no
what am i you're my son
what more than that
the casket wasn't the only thing you
took from yotenham that day was it
no
in the aftermath of the battle i went
into the temple
and i found a baby
small for a giant's offspring
abandoned suffering left to die
healthy sun
laughy son
yes
why you were knee-deep in youtube blood
why would you take me you were an
innocent child no
you took me for a purpose what was it
tell me
i thought we could unite our kingdoms
one day
bring about an alliance bring about
permanent peace
through you
but those plans no longer matter
so i am no more than another stolen
relic
locked up here until you might have use
of me why'd you twist my words you could
have told me what i was from the
beginning
why didn't you you're my son
i wanted only to protect you from the
truth well
because i i i'm the monster that parents
tell their children about at night
you know it all makes sense now why you
favored thor
all these years because no matter how
much you claim to love me
you can never have a frost giant sitting
on the throne of asgard
gods god please help
you